voici stv
alors steve hill le look voilà le look
steevy les antilles opaline les tontines
alors autre signe particulier de stevie
grain de beauté sous le bras gauche donc
ici ça
c'est via un autre il ya un deuxième
candidat sans ma verges
o o
ah ah
tu t'en sors bien sûr et peut être sur
la [ __ ] voix est-ce que stevie est ce
que vous vous sucer toujours le pouce oh
oui oui c'est sont tous issus sont polis
avec vous et avec qui il était en fait
il est avec son pouce valable et alors
bourrique et vous lave n'est plus là
votre peluche là c'est vrai il est chez
moi
rocco dans la noix bon vous êtes un des
rares lofteurs est devenu vraiment star
je suis pas une star aussi
merci mais non c'est vraiment pas le cas
même si vous prenez soin d'expliquer la
différence qu'il ya entre la notoriété
la célébrité vous êtes une star si c'est
évident tout le monde là tout le monde
l'a vu et puis ça va durer ben ça risque
de durer
mais ça reste dur a excellé en tout cas
il ya du fond bah je sais pas si il fait
vachement attention à son image c'est
vrai on fait pas de trucs bas de gamme
et on vous voit plus souvent avec jean
paul gaultier qu'en tournée dans les
discothèques c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai
rarement en discothèque
voilà est votre livre est d'ailleurs
assez assez haut de gamme l'album photo
qui s'appelle à davy jeanney alors ok
pas suivi regardes tu vas voir attention
tu fais pas là que pour ma promo est bon
on a un truc m'a dit c'est pas les gars
si ces senteurs médias
sur soi que vous ne ferez pas
l'équipement alors en voilà ce qui va se
passer
magnéto c'est et voilà comment ça
c'est truqué même quand vous serez pas
là je suis déçu par ces thèmes et voilà
bien alors vous voulez regarder le
formidable c'est à dire tenez voilà
c'est un très beau petit vie magnifique
la rondelle en quinconce non
lisez le bouquin moi je suis là t'as vu
c'est intéressant
stevie donc c'est pas une autobiographie
amont thierry j'ai remarqué ça ouais
c'est ça ton ouvrage si bien léché alors
c'est pas une autobiographie comme loana
c'est un album photos où vous avez
réalisé cinq voeux voilà alors le
premier veut c'était de partir en
vacances en famille ouais parce que
j'étais jamais parti en vacances avec ma
maman et ma soeur là c'est le premier
veut ensuite mis à manhattan vous
promener dans manhattan d'ailleurs on
voit bien la fin regard de laurent les
photos on voit les twin towers ont été
grisé voilà alors là c'est ce genre en
un hommage aux victimes des attentats
on cite souvent un hommage on dise
énorme pour eux si c'est pas grand chose
qui me rend pas compte ils sont dans la
merde sont terrorisés que le fait que je
fasse ça pour ça si j'avais su ça
ensuite qu'ils avaient vous baigner à
malibu et dîner dans un restaurant à bel
air qui était un quartier de los angeles
à côté de beverly hills la voile en
bretagne la vapeur est alors le dernier
voeu c'était un secret vous avez voulu
revoir la colo n'est pas l'avis du mans
où vous étiez quand vous étiez petit
village vous allez là-bas quand j'étais
petit à audierne voilà et j'y suis
retournée avec le député maire du mans
et alors là tous ces voyages de l'été de
stevie sont désormais dans cet album il
ya beaucoup d'émotions j'ai mis trois
quatre photos chez au bord des larmes
sècheront comme un arrêt c'est chaud bon
c'est pas chier soufflage voilà et
soufflage
alors je vais vous montrer la photo est
évident victoire quelqu'un regarde et
l'expression
m
l album bel album laisse le reste en
tout les deux steve est oui laisse-le
tomber bon alors donc il ya le bouquin
déjà à une première chose ensuite la
télévision feng steevy sur sur fun qui
vit à vous parler de musique vous parler
de mode
vous parlez de people et vous donner des
conseils c'est bien 850 français
accessible
donc vous êtes sur fun tv comme on l'a
dit en radio avec laurent ruquier sur
europe 1 s'est souvent l'après midi et
puis voilà pile reste du temps vous
passez votre vie et que les [ __ ] ou
a enfin plein de petits trucs pour une
petit projet on va savoir qui se cache
derrière cette image
[Applaudissements]
stevie c'est votre vrai prénom c'est bon
on va prénom steevy boulay voulait pas
manquer avec isabelle d'accord vous êtes
né à lille en 1981 et trois semaines
plus tard vous partiez pour le mans oui
on stoppe bain avec ma maman avec sa
maman alors apparaître votre maman
justement votre maman vous avez quand
elle avait 19 ans elle s'appelle zohra
elle a eu une enfance assez difficile
elle a été placée la dass parce que
c'est un enfant battu par sa mère est le
premier homme qu'elle a rencontré
c'était votre père on va là et elle
s'est retrouvée enceinte elle couche
avec l'huile surtout vincent vallat
c'est des choses qui arrivent
magnéto
jonquière ensemble est champion ensemble
quand elle découvre sa grossesse lui
deux mondes d'avorter mais elle ne veut
pas vers la refuse d'avorter
il devait partir en angleterre elle n'a
pas voulu partir en angleterre elle a
voulu garder son enfant
voilà heureusement qu'est ce qu'on
ferait sans lui et après la naissance
votre père décide finalement de faire
face et de l'épousé
voilà mais malheureusement quand arrive
le deuxième enfant aurélie votre petite
soeur
le couple se sépare parce qu'ils
battaient votre main il ya une scène
comme ça un jour je parle avec matin
jeudi mais j'ai une scène qui est dans
ma tête et qui me qui m'insupporte en
fait c'est j'étais petit 1 je devais
avoir trois ans mais c'est une scène qui
m'a marqué mais jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours
ma mère était enceinte je sais pas
c'était c'était assez je devais être sur
ces huit mois et je me souviens d'une
scène j'étais gamin j'étais avec ma
tante je tenais la main ma tante et mon
père ils arrivent ils avaient un peu
trop bu et il tient ma mère va chercher
une bassine à ma mère a dit nantes a été
capable de boire tu es capable d'aller
chercher une balle sinon ma mère elle
monte escalier il a pris ma mère ma mère
elle est tombé des escaliers alors
qu'elle était enceinte et je peux vous
dire vous êtes petit garçon et vous
voyez ça eva gens me dire que ça vous
reste dans lequel voilà c'était une
scène
enfin tant d'autres voilà donc votre
mère est obligé de faire des ménages
pour vous élevez parce qu'elle n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent voilà
et vous dites que quand vous étiez
petits dés fois la maison il y avait
deux assiettes pour 3 voilà alors ça
c'est aussi des scènes je voyais ma
maman qu'il faisait à manger bon bah on
n'avait pas les moyens manger souvent du
lait avec du pain on a mis les saladiers
t voilà et il y avait souvent deux
assiettes et au lieu de trois parce que
ma mère va nous regarder manger avaient
pris part à manger en entend moins fait
autre chose à repasser mais c'est vrai
que à chaque fois se voir dans le passé
il ya toujours deux assiettes sur cette
maudite table alors votre père il vous a
pas donné de nouvelles jusqu'à ce que
vous sortiez du loft et à la sortie du
loft votre père vous dis j'aurais pu
être dur avec toi mais regarde où tu en
es comme si la sévérité qu'il avait eu à
votre égard et est pour quoi que ce soit
en direct série
loft 1 ces enfants moi je sois pas la
vie comme ça ouais parce qu' un enfant
ça a besoin de son père voilà alors
quand vous étiez enfant vous n'avez pas
de vocation précise via des vétérinaires
je suis là est vite et rhys davies tunis
incite à la télé et présenter la météo
que ça vous arrive
pourquoi pas mais vous étiez persuadé
que vous seriez star quand vous seriez
grand mais je sais ce que j'ai toujours
dit à ma mère un jour maman je serai à
la télé et donc j'ai décidé de faire des
études dans l'audiovisuel j'ai obtenu
mon diplôme un en audiovisuel et voila
voila puis après il ya le loft on a
suffisamment parlé
la télévision a pas recommencer ce soir
vous êtes sorti le 24 mai et puis voilà
qui vous êtes parti en vacances est le
résultat de ces vacances c'est dans cet
album on va garder ce livre qui restera
je pense parce que c'est un bel ouvrage
oh la la il a été dressé jeudi alors à
paris la marge est la bonne nuit vous
fréquentez les vip et puis surtout on
peut les v6 quand même et puis j'aurai
avec marie myriam
c'est le même officier pendant le défilé
c'est assez marrant il favorable il fait
les mêmes pour moi bien je sais pas si
vous avez sais pas si vous avez la
morphologie pour porter du dossier je ne
pense pas que moi oui et non parce
qu'apparemment vous habillés en noir
parce que vous êtes mal foutu est ce que
j'ai compris
[Applaudissements]
bien c'est ce qu'on va dire ouais c'est
laurent ruquier qui vous a dit ça
non c'est pas leur envie dans dix ans
vous voyez caser avec trois enfants
j'aimerais ah bon si j'ai une petite
fille j'appelle kenza c'est un petit
garçon j'appelle kevin et si j'ai une
petite fille j'appellerai azilal et hop
parce que là attention il ya un gros
scoop gros gros scoop qui arrive là gros
scoop à stevie n'est pas homo alors
attendez moi je n'ai jamais parlé de ma
vie privée que je sois au mot que je
souhaitais que ce soit hétérosexuel que
soit mono sexuelle ça ne regarde
personne
non non il est déclaré dans ce journal
je ne suis pas homo vous avez déclaré
oui c'est vrai j'ai participé à la gay
pride avec mes cousins franck c'est
exact c'est raconter d'histoire mah mon
garçon c'est exact
neymar
tous
merci les enfants c'est vrai c'est vrai
que vous avez participé à la gay pride
avec votre cousin français lui est
homosexuel mais vous ne l'êtes pas c'est
vous qui avez dit ça j'en sais rien et
après tellement longtemps que j'ai pas
eu une aventure sexuelle
bah oui j'ai vraiment terminée par
croire que je suis mono sexuelle j'aime
à helwan à rien depuis jean edouard non
plus bah rien au ballon mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mais on peut s'assortir
vaille beaucoup attendant ça prend
quatre heures sinon vous ne diriez un
mois déjà bombe un an
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas des vues facile
parce que moi la personne je parle pour
moi par le pont des autres lofteurs
le matin je me lève lundi m6 mardi m6
mercredi
taiana gaulle oui je suis menacé celle
je me branle le 6 mai
magnéto serge c'est maintenant qu'on
lançait alors moi je vais dire quand
même le rêve de dusty vite que vous
l'avez d'éclat dans tous les cas dans la
presse
c'est une fille avec un garçon tué en
même temps le une fille avec des bosses
un bien formés havas est friand des
belles poitrines belle poitrine des
cheveux longs cheveux longs elle est
ouverte à tous est ouverte à tous
ouverte à tous voilà bien si vous sentez
concerné vous pouvez toujours envoyer un
email
sur le site de france 2 tout le monde en
parle voilà il y aurait eu une aventure
possible avec l'or dans le loft
franchement il ya un moment où oui
j'aurais vraiment pu faire l'amour avec
l'or mais mais il ya deux choses
prescient tu de ces cas les caméras
parce qu'avec ali chassé par allez-vous
sortait du lot de là l'hôtel accueille
chams
si je le vends un cas bénin
merci bon alors aïcha qu'est ce qui se
passe avec aïcha ouachin aïcha c'est sa
meilleure amie
c'est une amie d'enfance mais à l'époque
où il était amoureux d'elle elle était
avec un autre mec
donc il ne pouvait rien faire c'est vrai
c'est vrai quand j'étais plus jeune à
faire avec aïcha donc il sort du loft il
va à l'hôtel avec aïcha la première nuit
après le loft rien du tout non c'est non
mais loana l'avait déjà urgent et doit
jamais derrière quelqu'un tu as tu
entendu ça ça c'est bon à savoir
c'est une enfant qui veulent une classe
jamais derrière quelqu'un d'où
l'importance des peluches
quand il l'achète et surtout les neuf
enfin vous savez ce que je pense je vais
dire ce que je pense je pense que vous
avez été traumatisée oui par la perte de
votre chatte grise ou leur fassent non
mais ça c'est aussi c'est non on rigole
mais jamais dire que ce jour là
olemps occupé à sa shot
eva cassidy en l'honneur de green zone
nous allons faire une interview chatte
[Applaudissements]
je voulais mais il te déteste aussi
attention interview chatte vous êtes
prêts yes est ce qu'une chatte aime être
caressé oui combien de bébés peut avoir
une chatte 5
combien de temps dure la relation
sexuelle chez la chatte 20 minutes
non non de une à deux minutes ah ouais
ouais
ma chatte amérique beaucoup plus
longtemps un bon ça les tinner pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne l'avait jamais une
chatte la mine jal avait donc je sais
pas avant la chatte se lèchent avec sa
langue humide et rappeuse ouais c'est
bizarre parce que green enfin quand même
lui n'a pas ce 15e deuxième chaque matin
elle rentre enfin les deux rentrées avec
moi dans la salle de bain bien alors
dernière question de votre interview
chatte steevy comment reconnaît-on une
vieille chatte à la la moule qui bâille
steve darcis
donc comme sexe pour vous depuis un an
vous avez vous rattraper j'espère non il
va se faire très vite pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de inler 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu